We left off last Wednesday,
last week Wednesday.
So it's been awhile.
So I wanted just to pick
up where we left off.
And then cover some
new things today.
But where we left off was
with this diagram, OK?
And, you know, I kind
of went through it.
And I went through
it sort of quickly.
But I want to make sure you
understand it very well.
Because this is such an
important kind of diagram.
And we'll see it again.
And you may see it
again in other classes.
This is a diagram of
attraction and repulsion
coming together in a
balance to form a bond.
So, you know, last Wednesday,
just to remind you,
we made our first bond.
All right, we made
the ionic bond.
And I showed you
how that worked.
Because, in this
case, the attraction,
the force of attraction is
the Coulomb potential, right?
Remember that goes as
minus a constant times--
I'll just write it
down because why not.
You're using it
in your goody bag.
All right, so the
Coulomb energy here
goes as minus some constant
times the charges, the two
charges, divided by the
distance between those charges.
That's an energy.
It's an energy of attraction.
But, you know, so
here's the thing though.
All right, so if you have
a plus and a minus charge,
those are each 1, right,
charge of electron.
And then the distance
between them,
when it's really far this,
energy is pretty weak.
So that's this green curve here.
But as it gets
closer and closer,
that energy gets
lower and lower.
And remember, happiness
is lower energy.
All right, these atoms want
to find their happy place.
And they see each other
and they're like, well,
we can be happier
if we're closer,
until a certain thing happens.
Which is then, they've
got similar charges
like the electron
shells, negative charge.
Negative charge, so kind
of coming too close.
That's the forces of repulsion.
And so that nets in a
total energy curve, which
is this white line here,
the green and the red,
and then you got the
white line there,
which is the total energy.
Because if they came
too close, then you're
going to be on this thing.
And you're just
gonna be-- you know,
all those electrons are going
to be overlapping each other
and very unhappy.
So this is what we do.
And we said, OK,
this is the bond
of an atom and another atom, an
ion and another ion, a cation
and an anion.
We did all this Wednesday.
I'm just getting us
back in the mood.
And what I told you
is that that bond
energy is related to the
lattice energy, all right?
I mean, now, technically,
the lattice energy is--
and this is something
you're playing around with--
the lattice energy
would be the energy
that it takes to go from those
ions, sodium-plus in the gas
phase, right?
We put that little guy there.
Now, that is something that's
going keep coming, too.
It's in a notation
I've been sneaking in.
Gas phase, all right, plus
chlorine ion gas phase,
and they came together
to make NaCl--
ran out of room--
solid.
But I put it underneath,
solid sodium chloride.
That's salt. Now,
the lattice energy
is the energy that it
takes to go from these ions
to the solid.
And as you can see, well,
here I just did two ions.
But the lattice energy
is going to be related
to that bond energy, all right?
OK?
So the lattice energy of
the solid that you make
is going to be [INAUDIBLE].
And ionic solids, there's
a whole bunch of materials
that form solids this way.
They're ionic solids.
And they have properties
that are general.
They're not always
these properties.
But for the most part,
these are the properties
of our ionic solids, right?
They tend to be solid
at room temperature.
They tend to have high
melting and boiling points.
They're often transparent
in the visible.
They're mostly
electrical insulators.
They're hard and brittle,
soluble in water.
But in your goody bag, you're
seeing that's not always true.
Because sometimes, well,
most of the time there,
but if this lattice
energy is too high,
then it may not even dissolve.
It may still be an-- it just
may be some really, really
strong ionic solid.
But these are the general
properties of ionic solids.
We'll come back as we
learn about other solids
Wednesday to the
differences in properties
between different
types of solids.
OK, so that's where we ended.
Now, to do this, to get to
here, we had to make ions.
And so we've been
talking about ions.
And we're going to
keep talking about ions
because that's a very
important part of how atoms
see each other, all right?
Am I seeing you as a neutral
atom with all your electrons
in your shell or am I seeing you
with a charge missing or not?
That makes a big
difference in how
they approach each other
and therefore how they bond,
all right?
This is a critical part of what
we need to learn this semester.
And so, you know, we showed
this, which is sometimes
atoms actually don't mind
losing an electron, don't mind.
Don't mind is like
happiness level
which has to do with energy.
And so if we want to look
at this more formally,
we would look at, for
example, this chart
from [? Avril ?] which is
the first ionization energy.
Now, that's something
that we talked about.
So the first ionization
energy, which
is how much energy
it takes to remove
an electron from the outer
shell, the most outer shell
electron, the first one
you would take away.
That's the first
ionization energy.
All right, and we saw, again,
getting us back in the mood.
Oh, I've got colors there.
So if you started, for example,
let's just take a look at this.
OK, so here we are at lithium.
I'm going to start here.
And that's first
ionization energy.
And this is just
the atomic number.
So there's lithium.
And remember, we looked
at this last week, lithium
and beryllium.
OK, so if you look at that, we
said so for lithium, you had
three electrons in the core.
So there's lithium, right?
And there's the lithium.
Oh, this is so fun because now
we know what to call this--
1s2.
All right, and then
we have another shell.
These are just pictorial.
The electron is not in an
orbit, it's in an orbital.
It's not moving
around like this.
That's our classical
minds fighting.
And it's got one more electron.
Why did I draw a dash?
It's got one more electron
there in the 2s shell.
And that's lithium.
But now, we're going to go
from lithium to beryllium
and we talked about this.
So beryllium now is
going to add, OK, it's
going to add another proton.
It's got all of them.
But I'm showing the
one that was added.
And it's also going to
add an electron here.
But see, for beryllium
this electron
is really not shielded any
more, not shielded more
for the most part.
You know, it went into the same
shell, the same N, all right,
and the same L, same
shape, same quantum number.
So there's nothing
else shielding it.
And yet, there is a
whole other proton.
And that's why
beryllium is smaller.
This is all stuff we
talked about Wednesday.
But see, look, that's also why
it's harder to pull the outer
electron off of
beryllium-- there it is--
than lithium.
So those really go together.
All right, all the
radius stuff we
talked about holds, you
know, that same kind of logic
in terms of how
these electrons are
with respect to their nucleus
holds for ionization energy.
Now, let's go to boron.
So if we go to boron,
now, we're going over,
look at what happened.
Look at that.
We went from there to there.
And the ionization
energy got lower.
Well, that's also something
we can understand.
Because now, we're
putting it into the 2p.
OK, so if I do
that, it would be,
I'm going to put it
under here, 2s2, right?
And now, if I go
to boron, I'm going
to put it here in a 2p shell.
So I'm starting a
new L. Now, remember,
that means the quantum
number is still 2,
but the shape of the
orbital is different.
And now, we know
also from something
we learned last week that
because of orbital penetration,
the energies of the 2p and
2s orbitals are not the same.
All right, the s-energies
are a little lower.
And it lets those electrons
get a little bit closer
to that positive charge
that they want so badly.
So we know that this is going
to be a little further out.
And so there's a little bit of
shielding, a little shielding
that you get for this,
plus orbital penetration
that we talked about.
And that puts it
further out, all right?
And therefore, the
attraction is a little less.
ionization energy went down.
And now, we're going
to fill those up.
But it's the same
thing as before.
Now, you're not going further
out, you're just adding
and you're not really
screening while you add.
And so you're adding electrons
into this 2p orbital.
But you're also adding
all the positive charge.
Salute.
And so, the ionization
energy is going
to go up, except look at that,
half filling, right there,
half filling, a little
extra stability.
Remember, we talked
about exceptions, right?
Half filling.
And so, you see,
now you can see,
we can understand these trends
that were being measured.
All right, and at the
time, these ionization
potentials, but now we
really can understand them.
And you can group them.
And you can see if you group
them, remember, we also grouped
the periodic table a little bit
by electron filling, quantum
numbers.
All right, you had
the s and p blocks.
Those are also often called
the main group elements.
They're in the first
couple of rows of those.
They're the most
abundant elements.
But those trends, now,
you fully understand
from the quantum
mechanical solution
to the atom, all
right, and the electron
filling of those orbitals.
We can actually really
understand it all.
And then the same thing
happens with the d.
But it's a little
more complicated.
By the way, these are often
called transition metals.
The d-block, I told you
about the d-block last week.
They're also called
transition metals.
And the word metal
is something we'll
talk a lot about in a few
weeks when we make metals.
But they're called transitions
because, literally, they
transition in the filling.
They transition.
You're filling d-orbitals,
all right, transitioning.
And that makes it a
little more complex
in terms of what happens.
But the same trends hold.
The same trend holds.
As you add more d-electrons,
the ionization energy
keeps going up.
OK, now, this is extremely
important, this ionization
energy.
The first ionization
energy is very important
because it tells you so much
about the outer electron,
whether an atom is going
to be an anion or a cation.
But all of the
ionization, you could
throw a whole lot of
energy at these atoms
and they'll all
come off, all right.
And, you know, so we played
with this kind of energy.
This is visible light.
You had your goody bag, too.
You got a spectrometer.
You can see lines in here.
This is a continuous spectrum.
But you see, you've
got this whole,
all these different
wavelengths, right?
And now you see this and you
don't just think about colors,
you think about
energies, all right?
And so if you think that
way, because I want to know
how can I measure these things?
Ah, stop, better.
All right, and so, you know, if
I look at energies, energies,
I've got like the visible, which
is around, oh, I don't know,
say 2 to 6 EV.
That's pretty high energy.
And then you've got, well--
now, can I shine visible light
and kick out, you know,
a lithium electron?
Well, the answer is roughly yes.
You know, the lithium energy
ionization, well, let's just
go back and look.
That first ionization energy,
520 kilojoules per mole,
I know that's 5.4 EV-ish.
Because I don't mind going
back and forth, right?
Kilojoules per mole of
electrons, Jules, EV,
moles, you can go
back and forth.
But that's right around here.
So I could shine visible light
and potentially knock that out.
But see if I wanted the
1s electron of lithium,
well, it's much,
much lower in energy.
Because, remember,
we talked about this.
It goes in and in each
time I add charge.
And so it would take
122 electron volts
to knock that out, right?
So but we have that kind
of light, all right.
The UV would be something
like, oh, 10 to 100.
And then, if we really
want to blast these,
we could go x-rays.
Oh, are we going to
have fun with X-rays
later in the semester.
And this would go to
something like 100,000.
And so I got it.
You know, if I wanted to, I
could shine light and ionize
the whole thing.
And that is, in fact, one
of the single most important
experiments we do to
characterize materials.
And so I want you
to know about it.
It's called photoelectron
spectroscopy,
photoelectron spectroscopy.
And, for short, we will not
write that out ever again.
I will write out PES,
photoelectron spectroscopy.
Now, this is a
characterization tool.
I'm basically saying, well,
you know, I need energy.
I'm going to get it
from some photon source.
But I'm going to get
enough to just blast
all the electrons out of this
material, out of this atom.
Because, for now, our
material, they're just atoms.
And I want to know
about these atoms.
So let's take a look.
So what happens when I do this?
Well, let's see,
first of all, I've
got some energy that
we know is h nu.
It's dependent on the frequency.
There are the frequencies.
There they are.
No, there they are.
OK, so now, I've
got some atom here.
And what do I do?
Well, I look, did
anything happen?
No.
What about now?
I don't know.
OK, what about now?
Oh, all of a sudden, they
come flying out, electrons.
All right?
And I measure their energy.
It goes right back to
the photoelectric effect
that Einstein was doing.
He was shining visible-ish
light onto metals
and seeing what
electron-- but now I'm
shining all sorts of
light onto an atom
and I want them all to come
out, not just the outer one.
And so we will.
You can see if I
measure, so now I'm
going to measure the
kinetic energy of these.
And the ionization
energy of that electron
is going to equal whatever the
energy of the incident photon
was minus the kinetic
energy of the electron.
That's what I want.
I want that ionization energy.
This is, just to be
clear, ionization energy.
And like I said, I want it all.
Not just the first, I want
the second and the third.
So now, you see.
So this is the
experiment that you do.
What are the results?
Well, the results are really
just what we've been doing.
But you turn it over.
So let's look at hydrogen, OK?
Now, what have we been doing?
What do I mean by that?
Well, what we've been doing
is we've been going like this.
What's that?
OK, this is hydrogen 1s1.
I could do that or I could
just label it the 1s and then
you see the one
electron right there.
Now, if I shine light
on this and I measure,
the way that you do a
PES for hydrogen is you
would look at the ionization
energy on the x-axis.
And this would be the relative
electron count on the y-axis.
So you're just
counting, all right?
And what you would
see in hydrogen
is there would be a peak.
It would look like this.
That's it.
If all the electrons
in hydrogen, 1,
are in their ground state,
1s, then you would see a peak
and this would be, you know
that it would be at minus 13.6,
right?
That would be the energy
that it takes to ionize it.
And this would be the 1s peak.
And that's what you measure.
Now, it gets more fun,
because now I can also
look at other elements.
So let's draw helium
underneath it.
I'm gonna try to squeeze it in.
If I look at helium,
well, helium is also 1s.
And its PES would be--
so this is now
ionization energy.
This is the PES plot.
And the PES for helium
would be also the 1s.
But the relative counts
would be twice as high.
So the peak of helium
would be twice as high
as the peak of hydrogen.
Because, you know, for the
same number of photons in,
I'm getting that many more.
I've got both these
electrons coming out.
So the relative peaks, I've
got two more that can come out.
Now, if I go to--
OK, now, it gets
really interesting,
because now, oh,
I even have room,
which is making me very happy.
Because now I can do
lithium right here.
And if you look at
lithium, lithium
goes like this, all right?
And if I look at a PES plot
of lithium, the ionization
energy and the relative
electron count,
OK, I'm going to have
those 1s electrons filled.
And there's going to
be another energy where
the 2s electrons are.
So this is energy here.
These are the orbitals.
And somewhere over here is
going to be a peak that's
exactly half as high, exactly.
I mean, that's
makes a lot of sense
because there's twice
as many electrons.
It's the relative electron
count in the atom.
There's twice as many
electrons coming out
of that 1s orbital and the 2s.
So I'm going to get a half
as high peak here, all right.
And I just told you, the lithium
atom, this electron is 5 point
something, 4-ish
electron volts to remove.
This is 122.
So literally, for lithium,
this would be 122.
This would be 5.4.
And you know, that's the
ionization energy in EV.
And what you would do is you
would draw the axis like that.
So you don't have to put
this all the way over here,
all right?
And all this means is
I've broken up the axis
and it's continuing
to count here
in a different scale, all right?
These PES plots are absolutely
essential in understanding
atoms and materials.
Because look at what you get.
You get, literally, the electron
filling plot turned over.
It's incredible.
You get it turned over.
And you can write this as,
oh, let's just do this.
You know, I could
write this as 1s2.
We have so many
options now, 2s1.
All right, I could write
this as helium 2s1.
That would be like
using the noble gas.
I could make what people,
you know, there are so many--
I can make box
plots, oh, box plots.
You can do this.
Some people really
like putting things
in boxes, 1s, 2s, box plots.
So these are all meaning,
these all say the same thing--
Lithium.
They all say lithium, all right?
Photoelectron spectra.
So I could ask you
questions like this.
There's one.
Ionization energy, megajoules
per mole, relative number
of electrons, this element
has a charge of 2-plus
and the PES shown below.
What is it?
So, OK, I know, 1s2, 2s2,
and since this is going up
three times as high, that sure
looks like 2p6, doesn't it?
That looks like 2p6.
Remember, it's this
turned over on its side,
all right, where the peak height
corresponds to the filling.
That's what that
experiment gives you, 2p6.
Well, then it must--
But then you have your
periodic table, ah-ha.
Gesundheit.
Neon, it must be neon.
No, who said no?
No.
Don't just-- Yes, it can't be
neon because of the question.
It's got a charge of 2-plus.
Oh, tricky, tricky, tricky.
Magnesium, it must be magnesium.
That is the PES, right?
But it's magnesium 2-plus
because I said it had a charge.
Thank you, shout out,
I appreciate that.
OK, so that's the power of
the photoelectron spectra.
And we'll be using
it in the class.
And this tells us about
how electrons leave atoms.
It tells us about ionization
energies, not just
the first, which is
the one all the way
out here to the right on the
PES plot, but all of them.
Because I shine enough energy
light to get them all out.
Now, you can also--
so that's about
losing electrons--
you can also gain them.
And so I mentioned this a little
bit, but just for completeness,
I want to come back to this.
You have ionization
energy, which
is how much energy it takes
to pull an electron out.
You also have electron affinity.
Because some atoms also
might want electrons.
And so when you
look at those plots,
it actually all
makes sense again.
Look at this, some
atoms like chlorine--
this is electron
affinity by atom number--
some atoms like chlorine
really want another electron.
Why?
Because it's got an
incomplete shell.
It's so close.
It just needs one more electron
to fill that outer shell.
And it wants it.
And that's the electron affinity
is how much does it want it.
Now, want-- happiness,
happiness-- lower energy.
That's what this is.
So if you're not going
to lower your energy
with another electron,
then you're just saying no.
You just say no, 0.
I will not take an electron
because if you give me one,
my energy is going to go up.
And I will be a less happy atom.
Now, that makes
sense, too, right?
Filled shells.
Nitrogen, nitrogen has
got a half-filled shell.
"No" to that electron, I
like my half-filled shell.
It gives me a little added
stability, a little extra kick.
If you give me that
electron, you know,
I'm gonna not have
that added stability.
I don't want it, 0.
All right, 0.
Losing electrons, gaining
electrons, losing electrons,
gaining electrons,
why does it matter?
Why does it matter?
Well, we made a solid last week.
Today, the answer is obvious.
It matters because of
Danish wind, obviously.
43%, in 2014, 43% of all the
electrical energy in Denmark
came from wind.
It's higher now.
But see, now, this is a
quarter of the Danish wind.
I only gave you a two
minute hemodialysis
why this matters on Wednesday.
So I'm going extended
today just a little bit.
Danish wind, people
are very dependable.
So over a three-month period,
this is how much we need,
energy, electricity.
But look at the wind supply.
Sometimes it's
really there for us.
Sometimes it's not at all there.
Sometimes it's predictable.
Sometimes it's not
at all predictable.
With that much of
your electricity
coming from this type
of unreliable resource,
that is a huge challenge.
I mean, even if you
go out to Arizona
and you talk about
solar subsidies,
Arizona is sunny all the time.
No, not sunny all the time, most
of the time, more than Boston.
But this is the sun in Arizona.
That's the power
you're getting from it.
And look at this,
these are just clouds.
Because Arizona
does have clouds.
And they passed by and
they blocked the sun.
Do you know what a nightmare
this is for a grid operator?
If a lot of your customers
get their energy in this way,
you know, and all of a sudden,
half of the your supply
of energy just turns off, I
mean, that's a huge problem.
And this is one of the
most limiting factors
for increasing,
to a large extent,
the amount of renewables
we have on our grid.
And so, of course,
I know a lot of you
are thinking, well,
just store it.
And that's what we need to do.
But it turns out that
really one of the only ways
we have to store energy at this
large scale is pumped hydro.
And you see, we're
pumping water up a hill.
When I have access, I
pump water up a hill.
And then when I need,
I roll it back down
and I turn a turbine with it.
I'm literally just trading
energy, potential energy.
And then I bring it
back, kinetic energy.
And then I make electricity.
The problem is that, you
know, well, as you can see,
pumped hydro is going
to be good where there's
hydro, where there's water.
So that's limiting.
But it also is a very
low areal density.
And there are also a lot
of environmental challenges
with making this
work in a way that
doesn't harm the environment.
So there are a lot of
issues with scaling
up pumped hydro, a lot
of issues as a storage.
And so I ask, well, what
else can we pump up hills?
And we know what the
answer is because it's
what we're talking about--
ions.
Where are they?
Ions, we can pump ions up hills.
There's my picture.
Look at that.
Ions, and you know what
this is, it's a battery.
A battery is two
different materials,
two different metals, a and b,
where one of them has an ion,
I don't know, like
lithium, for example,
that can go back and forth.
And the electrolyte is
this thing in between
that only allows
that ion through, OK?
Now, here's the thing.
So if I'm a metal and I lose
a positively charged atom,
well, then I got
to stay neutral.
And the only way to stay neutral
is to pump an electron out,
all right?
So if I want to draw
electrons out of this,
that's fine as long as
I draw ions out of it.
And then both of
them can do work.
And then they come back and
they roll down an energy hill.
That's what they're doing
and going back and forth,
shuttling back and
forth, back and forth.
They're rolling down a
hill, literally, of energy.
You know, when it's in one
metal, it's higher in energy.
And then, when I, you
know, plug my phone in,
it rolls down that energy hill.
And as it does, it travels
across to the other metal,
gets lower in energy,
and the electron
has got to come around
and do work for me.
Because otherwise, it
wouldn't stay neutral.
That's what a battery is.
It's all about ions, all right?
It's all about ions.
It's like a ski lift.
I like to think of
it, you know, it's
like these ions are
getting into a ski lift
and they're just getting
pumped up the mountain.
And then when you plug it
in, they're ready to ski down
and they go down.
And that's just cruising
across this electrolyte.
And I don't know what the
electron is in this analogy.
But that's all a battery is.
You plug it in and the ski lift
takes it up when you charge it.
And now, you power your phone
on and it rolls back down.
Well, see the thing is
that batteries have seen
a Moore's law of themselves.
If you look at the Moore's
law for batteries, it doubles.
So this is the energy
storage of batteries
over the last 150-ish years.
It doubles every 60 years.
That's not a very
good Moore's law.
But that's completely changed.
That's completely
changed recently.
And the reason is all about
ion shuttling materials and ion
storing materials.
This is why this has happened.
This is why we've
had a revolution
in electrochemical energy
storage, all right.
Because 150 years ago, we
only made batteries out
of about 10 different materials.
And today, there's well over
80 that are commercialized.
There's many hundreds
in research labs.
What is making the difference
is that those materials now
allow the shuttling to happen.
It allows the shuttling to
happen more easily, maybe
faster.
And it allows more of them
to be stored per volume.
It's all about the chemistry
that houses those ions.
It's all about the
chemistry of the ions.
So that's why this matters.
Now, we roll things down
hills to power our world.
I told you this already in
the first or second lecture.
We roll things down hills
all the time, all right?
So like methane is the core
ingredient in natural gas.
And what we do-- and we talked
about combustion already--
is we light that
methane on fire.
But see, the thing is
that what nature has done
is it has put all this
stuff up the hill for us.
So over tens of
millions of years,
nature has pushed the
chemistry up a hill.
That is literally what
it's done in energy.
Because, you know,
it's made it so
that if I light this on fire,
it will go down the hill.
It will roll down the
hill and give off energy.
Nature has done that for us.
But see, we need to be able
to do this as well as nature.
And so in the last minute
of why this matters,
I want to explain why
this is so challenging.
We need to be able to match.
Because if you look at
the energy per weight
versus the energy per
volume of a material,
that's a very important metric.
We plot this all the time if
you work on energy materials--
the volumetric versus the
gravimetric energy density.
This is good, a lot of
energy per weight and volume.
Well, look at where gasoline is.
I want to do some math here.
Because I think this
is very important.
Because I want you
to see, now, if I
take one liter of
gasoline, so if I
take one liter of gasoline,
now, the cost is around $1.
Well, it fluctuates,
but, you know,
in this country right
around now it's about $1.
OK, now, if I look
at how much energy
is in that gasoline, the
energy stored in those bonds
that nature has pushed up a
hill over millions of years,
the energy stored is
about 33 megajoules.
OK, good.
Now, I'm going to
make a comparison.
One MIT professor,
one MIT professor
operates at around 60 watts.
Now, this is
something like-- well,
this is equal to 60
joules per second.
Now, I know some
professors who can
operate a little higher
than that and maybe some
a little lower.
But that's like the average--
60 joules per second.
Now, the thing is, if I want
to get 33 megajoules out
of this professor, then
I get, at this rate,
33 megajoules takes
the prof 153 hours.
Now, here's why this matters.
Because 153 hours
will cost about $1,530
at the MIT professor salary,
which is around $10 per hour.
And, OK, but look at this.
I dug something
out of the ground
that nature spent 100 million
years making, fine, OK.
And I burned it.
And I got it for a $1.
I got the same amount
of energy that it
would have taken me literally
$1,530 to pay for it.
That's our challenge.
Now, you can plot
other things here.
But look at this. ethanol,
wood, OK, liquid hydrogen,
we're still trying
to compress it.
But look at this, batteries
are way down there.
This is why this matters.
Because we're not even
close to being done.
We're not even close.
See that great uptick in
electrochemical storage.
We need another order
or two of magnitude
still in storing energy,
efficiencies, costs, et cetera.
So that's my "why this
matters" for today.
Now, back to ions and
electrons and atoms.
What I want to take the
last 15 minutes of class
is to introduce a new
way of looking at this.
And some of you may have
seen the Lewis dots, OK?
I'm going to
introduce them today.
And then we're going
to make a whole bunch
of molecular structures
on Wednesday.
And the reason this
is so important
is that it gives us a sense
of these outer electrons.
It gives us a sense of
how those outer electrons
look for the atoms, and
then, very importantly, how
they come together in bonds.
OK, how they come
together in bonds.
So if I just very,
very simply ask,
you know, what does the Lewis
dot structure look like?
Well, first of all,
the number of dots
is equal to the number
of valence electrons.
And this is equal to the
last digit of the group, so
of the element group.
I'll show you that in a second.
OK, so there's Lewis.
Now, Lewis, you know, so there's
one of his drawings in one
of his original papers
in the early 1900s.
He actually was a
professor here, as well.
And then he went and did a lot
of this work out in Berkeley.
And so they named
a hall after him.
And his contribution
was absolutely profound
because in thinking
about atoms with dots
to represent electrons
in the outer valence,
it gave us a way to so
easily think about bonding.
Now, we can think about
ionic bonding for sure,
which is what we've done.
But more importantly,
what Lewis helps
us with is to think
about covalent bonding.
And that's the
subject of Wednesday,
which is a whole
other type of bonding
that we're going to talk about.
OK, so now, the last digit of
the element group, OK, good.
So there it predicts number of
bonds formed by most elements
in their compounds, good.
And there is the dots.
Look at that example,
fluorine, or using
noble gas notation, helium,
that really saved us time.
I didn't have to write 1s2.
Actually, this looks like
four strokes of the pen.
1s2 would have been three.
I don't know, honestly.
But anyway, OK,
there is fluorine.
And look, one dot?
No.
Two dots?
No, because you add a
dot for the valence.
So fluorine has seven dots
until you reach the valence,
until you reach the valence.
That is the key of
the Lewis picture.
And we talked about this before.
We talked about this before.
Because it showed there were
three really important things
that come out of
the Lewis picture.
One is it tells us,
as I've just told you,
it tells us about
bond formation.
It tells us about
And it makes the assumption
that the valence electrons
are what matter for chemistry.
And this is critical.
And I've alluded to this before.
You now have a real
sense of this, though.
From these energy diagrams,
you have a sense of this.
Because look, if I want to rip
an electron off of lithium,
I got to spend 5.4
electron volts.
If I want to rip
the next one off,
I got to spend over
100 electron volts.
And we said, well, we'll do
PES with all these energies.
It doesn't matter.
I'll get 'em all.
But what if I just
want to say, well,
what electrons are going to
be available to participate
in something like a bond?
Which ones?
It's going to be these ones.
It's not going to be the
ones all the way in close
to the core that don't
want to be bothered
and they've got so much energy.
Just to get their
attention takes 100 EV.
And even that's not a--
But here, a little
visible light and I
got lithium talking to me.
Well, chemically, it's the same.
That's light, right?
These ones are the ones
that want to and can
participate in bonding.
The ones all the way down in
energy, way, way, way low,
they're inert.
They're inert, all right?
So most of chemistry
happens in the valence.
And Lewis really nailed that.
So these dots are only
valence electron dots.
And there's one more rule.
Now, OK, so there is the
seven dots for fluorine.
And then, OK, sometimes
you'll see this.
Oh, this is just
the number of dots.
It's this classification
of the columns, all right,
the groups in a pair.
But, no, that is not
OK, not standard.
Remember, the
IUPAC, which throws
the best, most lively
parties and conferences,
they decide on how
to name elements.
And many, many other aspects of
our lives are decided by them.
And they said, no, that's
an old classification.
It's confusing.
So we're going to go with the
standard, which is that we
still count 1 to 18, 1 to 18.
1, 2-- s-block.
13 to 18-- p-block.
All right?
OK, that's cool.
3 to 12-- d-block.
We're going back and forth.
But you can just take the last
digit there, IUPAC standard.
Even the periodic
table talks about it.
It shows it.
It shows the old
classification there.
And then it says, no, don't
use it, it's confusing.
Well, then why do they show it?
Because some textbooks
still show it.
So I want you to
be aware of that.
OK, now, you can
use Lewis, you can
use this idea of only
thinking about the valence
to understand when atoms have
similar chemistry, all right?
So if the valence of
carbon is the same
as the valence of silicon,
you've bumped down one quantum
number, but they both
have 4 electrons out there
in the valence.
In this case, it's 2.
In this case, it's 3, in
terms of the quantum number.
But they both have
those same kinds of
and same number of electrons.
So you can maybe expect there
to be similar chemistry.
It turns out, in
this case, there
is very different chemistry.
But we'll learn about that.
Carbon-- hybridisation.
Silicon-- no.
We'll get to that.
But still, this is how
we see silicon now.
We don't see it
this way with Lewis.
We see it this way.
This is how we see carbon.
And so I want you to start
seeing elements this way.
OK, and so you can
look at periodic tables
and take images randomly
found online with Lewis dots.
And you can start
thinking of atoms
as their Lewis-dot
representation.
And like I said,
on Wednesday we're
going to make a whole bunch
of structures, molecules,
with Lewis dots and show
how that teaches us,
not only about how
to draw the bonds,
but, literally,
about which bonding--
You know, if I have sodium and
chlorine, it's pretty obvious.
If there is a bond, it's between
sodium and chlorine, all right?
But as I go to
more and more atoms
and I'm trying to
form molecules,
it's not so obvious what
is bonded to what and how.
All right, and
thinking about this
and thinking about the
third part of what Lewis
did that was so
important is what
allows us to draw a whole
bunch of molecules--
Octet rule, which
is that atoms like--
we now know "like"
means lower energy--
to reach 8 electrons
in their valence.
OK, well, we can already
see this for the ionic bond
that we've talked about.
And you can write this.
And I want you to write
ionic bonds using Lewis.
But in this case, it's actually
pretty straightforward, right?
If I had, for example--
let's get some more
board space over here.
If I had, for
example, an ionic bond
between cesium and fluorine, so
if I had cesium and fluorine,
then the way I would think
about this in the Lewis world
would be this way and this way.
Because I've got 7 valence
electrons in fluorine and 1
in cesium.
And then, if I write
this as an ionic bond,
the way I would write it is
cesium-plus with fluorine
having taken that electron.
And so you would write this
still with the minus sign
there.
That emphasizes.
It emphasizes what happened.
But I see my Lewis here.
You know, I see it there.
But I'm emphasizing that this is
an ionic bond that's happened.
Because fluorine wasn't supposed
to have 8, but then it did.
It's got a super-high
electron affinity.
Cesium has a very low ionization
energy of its first electron.
And so fluorine just took it.
It literally just took it.
I'll take that.
Thank you very much.
You know, I'm not
being judgmental.
But ionic bonds are
kind of, you know,
the relationship in a bond--
and I don't want to judge--
but the relationship
is not even.
It's not even.
And that's OK.
But fluorine said,
take, take, give.
And cesium atom, OK, fine.
Now, on Wednesday when we do
covalent bonds, it's not so--
then there's a lot more
sharing that happens.
And that's why we can
model it the way that I--
yes, I still left there--
we can model it that way.
Because it is like a charged
atom and another charged atom,
all right?
And it's because
fluorine took it.
Fluorine took it.
It's OK.
Any kind of relationship,
you know, they get along.
They make it work.
Now, what we can also do
just in thinking about this,
just in thinking
about this, I can
go to another
example like calcium.
And if I think about
calcium and fluorine,
well, I know again fluorine
likes to be f-minus.
But see, calcium, when I think
about it as a Lewis atom,
you know, calcium likes
to lose both of those.
Calcium, often,
because, remember,
they want to get
to the Octet rule.
They want to reach
their 8 electrons.
But calcium has got
2, what do I do?
Either somebody gives me
6, not going to happen,
or I can lose 2.
And so what you get is
that calcium will go,
you know, to Ca2-plus.
But fluorine is
still just f-minus.
Right from this I know that
the balance stoichiometry, that
is to say how many
calcium atoms I need
to stabilize this whole
ionic bond situation,
is going to be 2, right?
I got to go to calcium F2.
And if I were
going to write this
with emphasizing
the ionic bond, I
might put brackets around just
so it's really easy to see,
2-plus.
There's no dots left.
Because now I'm writing
it in a way where
I've emphasized that--
gesundheit-- that F took it.
It took it.
And it is minus.
And there's two
of them, you see?
So that would be like thinking
about an ionic bond, all right,
but from the Lewis-dot
vantage point where I really
see that fluorine
took the charge, OK?
OK, so I think--
oh, ho, you could go further.
You can go further.
I think we'll stop there.
And on Wednesday, like I said,
we're going Lewis all the way
and we're doing covalent
molecules, covalent bonds.